- Spanxsgiving!
- We could do yoga, as well.
- We're here!
- I'm here with Louis
Cole, AKA Fun For Louis!
And we're wearing the
same clothes because we're
about to, uh, we're about to--
- What are we about to do?
- Oh, God.
We've created a challenge
here called the Spanxgiving
Challenge.
Now, one of the most common
things that you do on
Thanksgiving is you stuff
yourself with a variety of
Thanksgiving food.
And one of the things that Spanx do,
they keep all the food in.
And one of the things
that we don't have is time
to sit down and have a meal together.
So, instead we're gonna
combine all those things
into this challenge.
You and I, Louis, are gonna
put Spanx on over our clothes.
- Okay.
- And then we are going
to play a game in which
Jack Ferry will read us quotes
from a variety of YouTuber
books and we will have to
race to guess who's book
that quote is from.
- Okay.
- The person that gets it
right, then gets to choose
a Thanksgiving food item to
stuff into the other persons
Spanx.
- Brilliant.
- Just like real Thanksgiving
with your families, right?
This is what happens.
- And this is so new for
me because in England
we don't have Thanksgiving
and we don't have Spanx.
- Welcome to America!
(both laughing)
First thing we're gonna
do is we're going to put
our Spanx on.
Hopefully, oh my God.
(laughing)
- I better not pull it up too tight.
- Okay.
I'm getting some shorts action.
- Should I do that?
Is that a better style?
- I mean--
- Whoa, where have they gone?
(laughing)
- Who needs Spanx underneath your clothes
when you can wear them
on top of your clothes.
You look great!
- You look great.
- Thank you!
Okay, now that the Spanx are in place,
we can begin Spanxgiving.
(dramatic music)
So the books that we have
available to guess quotes
from are Connor Franta's
A Work In Progress,
Marcus Butler's Hello Life,
Tyler Oakley's Binge Book,
Louise Pintland, Life With
a Sprinkle of Glitter,
Zoella's Girl Online
On Tour, Shane Dawson,
I Hate My Selfie, Pewdiepie,
This Book Loves You,
Hannah Hart's My Drunk Kitchen,
Joey Graceffa, In Real Life,
The Amazing Book Is Not
On Fire, from Dan and Phil,
You Deserve a Drink from
Mamrie Hart, and Selp
Helf from Miranda Sings.
- Where's your one?
- Not worth this.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] Okay,
this is the first quote.
"They love to say love it
blind, it's either that
"or you'll have to date a blind person."
- Love to say love is blind, either that,
you'll have to date a blind person?
Hanna Hart, My Drunk Kitchen?
- [Voiceover] No.
- I'm gonna say Shane Dawson.
- Uh, Tyler Oakley, Binge Book.
- [Voiceover] No.
- What the?
Mamrie Hart?
- [Voiceover] No.
- [Both] What?
- Dan and Phil.
- [Voiceover] No.
- What?
- Connor Franta?
- [Voiceover] No.
- Pewdiepie?
- [Voiceover] Yes!
So you get to choose
a Thanksgiving food to
stuff my Spanx with.
(laughing)
- All of this food is like squishy.
- Yep, that is true.
- I'm gonna start with
macaroni and cheese.
What else is in there?
(laughing)
- I'm ready!
(screaming and laughing)
- There you go.
(laughing)
- Next quote.
- [Voiceover] "Everyone
got rip roaring plastered
"within the first hour and I
couldn't have been happier."
- Mamrie.
- [Voiceover] Yep.
- Mother (ding).
- How did you not get that?
- Because I was debating
between Hannah's and maybe
Tyler's, okay, go ahead.
Stuff the Spanx.
- Oh God.
- I didn't even think about that!
- This is a great game!
Exercise, as well.
- Yeah it's really working but--
- Just get it down there.
(screaming and laughing)
- Wait what are you pouring down there?
- I don't know, pumpkin.
It's seeping through,
it's seeping through.
I can't get it further down.
- No!
Okay, what's the next quote?
- I love this.
- [Voiceover] "A brain fart
is when you write out the
"first thing that comes into your head
"with no filter."
- Shane Dawson!
- [Voiceover] No.
- Tyler Oakley?
- A brain fart?
- Joey?
- [Voiceover] No.
- Dan and Phil?
- [Voiceover] Yes.
(laughing)
- I feel bad now.
- It's all good, I invited you here.
(laughing)
- You ready for this?
- Yep.
So ready.
(screaming and laughing)
- Oh my God.
I'll just give you one lump, there you go.
- Aw, thank you.
Aw, thank you.
It's a great odor that's emanating.
Bath and Body Works needs a suggestion for
candle scents, feeling great.
You look great.
- Thanks.
You still enjoying this idea you have?
- Yes, I love this idea.
This is innovative and ground breaking.
Eat shit traditional media.
Three to zero.
I'm just shouting everyone's name out now.
- [Voiceover] Okay,
"Stand strong on drinking,
"if you're offered a drink
and would prefer not to drink,
"just don't."
- Connor Franta.
- [Voiceover] No.
- Mamrie.
- Shane Dawson.
- [Voiceover] No.
- Tyler Oakley.
- Louise!
- [Voiceover] Yes, Louise.
- Yes!
- Aw, you got one.
- We're going gravy.
- Oh God.
- [Voiceover] Alright,
"Speaking of gymnastics,
"I hated knowing that
no matter what I did,
"a certain group of kids
were going to give me crap
"for being good at a sport I loved doing."
- Joey Graceffa.
- [Voiceover] No.
- Connor Franta?
- Marcus Butler.
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- (ding) Bullshit!
Okay.
- Gymnastics.
Who did gymnastics as a kid?
- Yeah, great, you know what I did?
This as an adult.
- I'll get you back for
this gravy, you know.
Everything has to fit down there.
- Well, you'd be surprised.
Spanx have a--
(screams)
- [Voiceover] Here you go, next quote.
"Celebs I'd love to be best friends with,
"Jennifer Lawrence, all
I want to do is hang out
"at her house with her inner circle of
"friends and talk--"
- Joey.
"And laugh." Yes.
- Yes.
We'll do stuffing.
You got to have something
to sop up the gravy.
- Front or back?
- The front.
(all laughing)
- Do not turn to the
side, whatever you do.
(laughing)
Okay, four to two.
- [Voiceover] "The smell
of death and bags of pee
"filled my nose as I layed
in silence on the crunchy,
"plastic sheet."
- Smell of death and bags of pee.
Shane Dawson?
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- Aw.
- Okay, please turn around.
Okay.
(laughing)
It looks great.
Okay, four to three.
- [Voiceover] "Every wedding
I've ever attended has
"been an absolute disaster."
- Miranda?
- [Voiceover] No.
- Connor?
- Mamrie?
- [Voiceover] No.
- Louise?
- Tyler?
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- Ah!
Tied up, tied up, tied up!
I'll put some mashed potatoes in.
- Down here?
- Down the side, let's do the sides,
let's give you a shape.
(laughing)
You've got curves!
I'm giving you an
hourglass figure right now.
Okay, we're tied up,
this is the game winner.
- [Voiceover] "When going
through the highs and lows
"of a breakup it's all too
easy to become modern day
"Sherlock Holmes."
- Shane?
- [Voiceover] No.
- Louise?
- Joey?
- [Voiceover] No.
- Miranda?
- I'm just feeling cold
stuff on my butt right now
so I'm getting distracted.
Zoella?
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- I was just about to say her!
- Yes!
And last, but not least,
some beautiful yams.
I'm just gonna dunk the whole thing.
(laughing)
Thank you, Louis, for being
such a willing and able
participant in Spanxgiving with me!
Don't forget to say Spanx for--
(screaming and laughing)
If you guys want to hear
more about Louis and all
his goings on, listen to the
full podcast that we recorded
on Sound Cloud or iTunes
and subscribe to Louis
all across social media.
How do they find you?
- Fun For Louis.
Fun, For, Louis, L-O-U-I-S.
- Across everything.
- And if this doesn't prove
that he's someone worth
following on social media,
I don't know what does.
Also, I just, I don't know.
- So I got arrested
stepping off the plane--
- And this elderly
couple that's just like,
"We'll never trust youth again!"
- It was this look of horror
as I glanced back and they're
like staring at me.